hey guys Pete here so this is the
follow-up to my video yesterday it's
gonna be my part 18:10 things you might
have missed video if you haven't watched
the return of Twin Peaks all the way
through to the end of the series then
you're gonna want to stop watching this
video right now cuz it will have major
major spoilers so I was working on this
for the last couple days and it's kind
of frustrating because there's so many
good theories out there and it's kind of
affecting my point of view a little bit
I tried to pick these out in an
objective way though because there's
actually several theories out there that
make some sense they all have good parts
and a lot of times I think that the
writing is what wins you over whenever
you read it like if someone really makes
a good case for what they're saying it
pulls you into that theory but I do
believe that it's supposed to be
somewhat open-ended and you know I've
never made my videos in a way that I
wanted to try to tell anybody what to
think but rather just put all the stuff
out there so you could draw your own
conclusion so anyways let's jump into it
so the first thing you might have missed
was that the power lines at the 4:30
mile marker have the definite
resemblance to the alcove symbol and the
marking we saw of what we expect to be
Judy on evil coupes ASIS space it's
interesting about this is that when I
first saw it I thought you know well
that's kind of a interesting little
trick to make us realize that that's an
evil place or whatever but when you
think about it that's not what it is at
all or at least I don't think so anymore
it's the 430 is something that came
directly from the giant so it's really
just a part of the plan it's a you know
it's just a marker to help agent Cooper
and I am know that they're going the
right place the second thing you might
have missed is the song that's playing
when Cooper and Diane have their little
lovemaking session is the same song that
was on the radio and episode 8 it's a
tune called my prayer and you know it
was playing whenever the woodsman went
into the radio station and started
breaking people's heads so it is the
same song it's from a band called the
platters
and interestingly enough there's a guy
in the band named David Lynch that's not
the director of this movie David Lynch
does it mean something directly well I
don't think that they would use the same
song otherwise I don't have a great
explanation other than it connects those
two scenes together and why I think
that's important ties into the next
thing that you might have missed and
that is that Cooper especially but Diane
and Cooper together have a plan once
they get into that hotel room and it
looks to me like they understand it'll
be uncomfortable if not a painful
experience so what we saw when we heard
that song play the last time was we saw
the woodsman repeat his saying or his
hypnotic chant or whatever you wanted to
call it over and over until the
townspeople went to sleep and eventually
that Mothe frog could enter the little
girl's mouth this could be the same sort
of thing or it could be the opposite
thing this is where the different
theories start to converge and I won't
go into it too deeply here but I do
think that this was a ritualistic thing
that they did their doing here there's
talk about sex magic and Jack Parsons in
the secret history which wouldn't be
there for no reason I wouldn't imagine
and without going off on a complete
tangent I would just say that I think
that what they're doing here is similar
to what that would be it could be a
summoning thing like I said or it could
be more of an opposite where they're
trying to seal off this area or this
alternate dimension so that Judy can't
get back out we'll remember in the
beginning of the series
whenever Sam and Tracy had sex that
that's when Judy came into or we called
her the experiment model at that point
but something either Judy or an avatar
or whatever you would want to call it
came through the glass box is was
probably in direct relation to the fact
that they were doing that so coop and
Diane has a it's a very weird scene and
it has a lot I mean it goes on for a
long time neither one seems to be
enjoying it and it seems to me that
is something that they knew was going to
happen and they were doing it for a
specific purpose you could say that you
know Diane saw her doppelganger outside
and that's an indication of her fear
about what happened in the past with
evil coupe and that's why that they knew
this was going to be a bad experience or
whatever but I think the fact that coupe
is just not really engaged when we've
seen him that way in the other other
scenes when they're affectionate so you
know what I mean like I think that it's
not so much that Cooper's a different
person here it's that he understands the
gravity of the situation they're doing
this for a greater good not for pleasure
and that's not to say that I don't think
Cooper changes over his time in this
dimension but we'll get into that later
so the next thing that you might have
missed but probably not because it was
pretty darn obvious was that the motel
and car change overnight they're in like
what looks like a 60s model Lincoln
whenever they cross over they check into
a one-story motel in room 7 but when
they wake up coupe gets the note from
Diane that says that you know he's
Richard and she's Linda and then when he
walks out we see that the motel is
completely different it's two stories
now and that the car is a newer model
similar to the one that he drove earlier
in season 3 as evil coupe again I think
this is actually a clue to the fact that
this is all part of his plan since they
now have the names that the fireman
spoke to coop and you know that scene in
the very beginning initially after the
episode aired there were theories
popping up that maybe Richard was who
coop really was and everything before
that was a dream I never really thought
that sounded right and when you watch it
again it gets even more unlikely to me
it seems like coop is still himself but
he becomes less connected to that self
as episode 18 goes along this gives way
to the idea that he has to remember who
he is in this journey and what the
ultimate goal is or they will in fact
lose the next thing you might have
missed was the white horse totem in
Carrie Paige's house
I've been calling it a totem in my own
head canon since the definition of totem
basically means like an animal or
natural object that has some kind of
spiritual significance to a society or a
group of people and then they take that
on as their emblem this particular horse
is the way that it's positioned on the
mantle kind of liked it kind of looks
like the horses the white of the eyes
and the dark within so this is likely in
reference to Judy of course like other
white horses and that imagery we've seen
in other scenes throughout the series
really the next thing was a telephone
pole outside it has the number six plate
on it in which we've seen in other
locations you probably noticed this
right away but it's interesting because
this is the same one that we saw the
giant show Andy in that sequence
whenever he got sucked into the vortex
this is a pretty heavy-handed hint that
the fireman knew what was gonna go on
before Cooper and Diane crossed over
which should also mean that Cooper knew
as well doesn't mean that the fireman
constructed this world within a world
that's up for debate different people
have different feelings about that I
think it makes more sense that he did
instead of say the alternative idea that
Judy made this world so that you know
she could trap coop and Laura in the
same place it makes a whole lot more
sense that this was set up by the
firemen as a way of keeping Judy away
from the world that we knew before the
next thing you might have missed was the
double are actually looks different when
they pass it when Richard coupe and
Carrie Laura dry past the double are the
double are to go logo isn't painted on
the front of the building anymore this
has been mentioned in connection with
the idea that this alternate dimension
could have been constructed by Laura
since she would remember what the Double
R looked like when she was alive this is
another rabbit hole that I'm not going
to get into right at this moment but
that does make a bit of sense although
it could also be consistent just what's
the fact that that wouldn't have
happened maybe in the alternate version
of the story the next thing you might
have missed is that the woman who plays
Alice
Trainmen is the actual current owner of
the palmer house the house now there in
Everett Washington is owned by Mary and
Timothy rubber and they bought it in
2014 which is pretty cool because they
got to be in the movie and folks found
this out because one of their children
had tweeted it after the episode now
that's a neat little easter egg but it's
really not the most important thing
because you probably didn't miss the
fact that it's no coincidence that those
are the names that they have you know
the cow fonts and the Train moans and it
means that there is a definite influence
or direct connection to the lodge we
know that our hero call rod mentioned
that there were two families named Chau
Fonz that rented the space at the old
fat trial where Chet Desmond disappeared
we know that the Chau fonts is the name
that's been used by the old woman as
well as Tremont so even though this
alternate reality doesn't have Sarah
Palmer living in that house it does in
fact still have Judy's influence in one
way or the other and that's pretty much
where we get to the last thing and again
it's not something that you miss but
it's something that we need to talk
about the electricity goes out in that
house in a fairly dramatic fashion and
if you think about the way the scene is
set up Cooper comes out he looks like
he's having a very hard time keeping it
together at this point perhaps he's
losing his connection with his reality
that he left behind temporarily to go on
this mission we hear after he says what
year is this we hear Laura's mother from
the pilot say her name yellow her name
like she did and this causes Laura to
remember and scream at this point this
is all happening in real time in this
dimension so it's not like this is some
kind of trickery or some kind of
dramatic filming or filmmaking I should
say in order to just put a you know a
period on the end of the sentence
something clearly happens when she
screams doesn't mean that Judy is then
defeated I mean it probably does if you
think about it a lot of people have
brought up this idea of playing both
of these episodes together and I'm not
mad the jury's still out on this for me
like I don't know for sure that it was
done on purpose
at least not the whole episode because I
started watching it before I read any of
the theories and it just didn't stand
out as being like intentional at first I
did read the theories later and they're
fine but you don't really need to watch
both episodes at the same time to get
that same explanation you know what I
mean the informations there either way
and I don't agree with the entirety of
it but that's how all of them are
there's quite a few good ones there's
the real world one there's the idea that
you know Judy created this world to try
Cooper and then there's the idea that
it's the pocket dimension made by the
giant to trick Judy and they all have
pretty good write-ups to go along with
them and they all kind of make sense so
I think what we witness here though is
we do witness a destruction of sorts you
know the theme of electricity has been
recurring throughout this series and
we've seen laura has been presented as
the entity to balance out against 2d so
it would appear to me that we're at
least supposed to think that it's
possible that it happened and you know
we cut to the the scene of her
whispering in Dale Cooper's ear in the
Red Room and you could kind of figure
out how she might just be explaining the
plan or what they have to do and this is
kind of a good ending but it's kind of a
bad ending because if you think about
that the reason why they want to get
Judy out side of the world and contain
her was because her destruction would
probably destroy a lot more along with
her and that means that Cooper and Laura
probably die as well
can't know any of that for sure but I
can't imagine that that would be
completely popular or adopted as a
for-sure kind of ending to the series
and to the character of Dale Cooper so
we will think about this for a long time
and that's good as far as I'm concerned
there's going to be desperation for
people to insist that they're correct in
their interpretation if the past
dictates the future there really won't
be a right answer
and you know like I said for what it's
worth I don't think that it's better if
you look at the reality of what these
two guys have put together David Lynch
and Mark Frost it doesn't seem very
likely that we'll ever know for sure or
that they made this little Easter Egg
that if you play both episodes at the
same time suddenly everything makes
sense I do think we'll get a lot more
about things in the final dossier but I
don't think it'll be all that much
different than anything else that we've
had in the twin peaks' universe I think
that it would just give us more to think
about and you know they're they're
familiar with the fact that there's a
hive mind out there trying to solve
their mystery so they're not going to
give it to anybody very easily but they
will stoke the fires and I'm excited
about that so give this video a like if
you'd liked it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already please
think about coming over and joining me
on patreon I've had a lot of people ask
about doing the original series again
seasons 1 2 and fire walk with me now
that we have more information I think it
sounds like a fascinating idea that you
know this is the reason why I started
the patreon in the first place is
because that you know videos like that
take a day if not more the way that my
schedule works is I have to make things
that are going to get views and I don't
know that through the entirety of that
that they would get views like I've
already seen a big drop-off in Twin
Peaks views since the premiere has only
been over for a week already so I have
to be able to keep myself afloat so if
you want to come over and if we can get
some support over there I'd be glad to
do a couple of those a month and we'll
get through it overtime and if not I'll
just do what I can do so please follow
me on my social media accounts we have a
pretty good lively group over there
nowadays on Twitter some interesting
back-and-forth going on so join in with
that thanks for watching guys I'll talk
to you soon